Big shot gangster putting together crew... you in
Wait a long time for a shot like this
What are you doing with having the boy we need a ship the Millennium Falcon
Every ship isn't for everyone she needs a particular type of pilot done flirting
These people not your friends
There's a lesson to be learned here
Got a really good feeling about this
You're after something
Is it revenge
Money
Or is it something else
You look good little rough around the edges, but good
Heard about a job big shot gangster putting together crew
I'm a driver
And I'm a flier
The waited a long time for a shot like this
What do you think
Well, what do you know?
You got a line on the ship. Yeah, no guy either by smuggler around. I heard a story about you
I was wondering if it's true everything you read about me. It's true
L-3 let's go with a mean man's face, who are these guys?
If you come with us you're in this life for good might wanna buckle up, baby
Let me give you some advice
Assume everyone will betray you and you will never be disappointed. I got a really good feeling about this
When do you know how to fly me a hundred and ninety years old. Look great
You